sur ce même écran ou je me présente ce
soir devant vous pour la première fois
monsieur alain poher président de la
république par intérim rappelé jeudi que
notre pays est une démocratie majeure
or il est une règle fondamentale de
toute démocratie que la majorité décide
des choix importants
il semble bien qu'en france depuis
quelques temps nous soyons dans une
démocratie si nous y sommes qui
méconnaît cette règle fondamentale et je
n'en prendrais pour preuve que trois
exemples
le premier concerne la l'opinion des
français face aux structures de
l'entreprise
dans un sondage réalisé par la sofres en
1972 54 p ce pour cent des personnes
interrogées se sont déclarées favorables
à ce que les représentants élus du
personnel détermine le niveau des
salaires et 59% on estimé de même pour
les conditions de travail dans
l'entreprise
une majorité de français s'est donc
prononcé à l'évidence en faveur d'une
participation réelle des travailleurs à
la prise des décisions qui les
concernent
pourtant depuis lors en dépit de
l'expression de cette majorité
les structures de l'entreprise n'ont pas
été modifiées
et on a même préféré répondre à cette
aspiration
une majorité de français par une phrase
sans réplique souvenez-vous l'ip c'est
fini et on a préféré demander
accessoirement de continuer le dialogue
on compagnies républicaines de sécurité
un deuxième exemple marc que les limites
de la démocratie de notre dans notre
pays
il s'agit de la régionalisation un
sondage sofres encore tout récent
indique que 68% des français sont
partisans de l'élection au suffrage
universel direct d'une assemblée
régionale et dans le même sondage
on relève que 70 % des français estiment
qu'en cas de difficultés susceptibles de
se présenter quand à la délimitation des
régions il convient de consulter par
voie de référendum les populations
concernées
une nette majorité de français s'est
donc prononcé en faveur de région
autonome
disposant de pouvoirs réels de
ressources propres
cinq siècles de centralisation
méthodique forcené durant lesquelles on
a bâillonné les minorités linguistiques
et culturelles durant lesquelles on a
écrasé les collectivités locales sous le
carcan administratif de l'état cinq
siècles de centralisation méthodique ne
sont donc pas parvenus à mettre un terme
à l'expression des diversités régionales
en dépit de ce sondage depuis là les
structures de l'état
figés depuis le xviiie siècle n'ont pas
été modifiées on s'est borné à mettre en
place des régions artificiellement
technocratiquement à découper
ne disposant d'aucune institution
représentative et n'ayant pour toute
ressource
quelle dérision que les taxes sur les
permis de conduire et sur les cartes
grises
troisième exemple celui l'europe on a
organisé en novembre 1973 dans
l'ensemble des états de la communauté
européenne un vaste sondage
en france 57 % des français interrogés
ont souhaité qu' une évolution vers la
formation politique des états unis
d'europe et 51% ont souhaité que le
parlement européen soit élu au suffrage
universel direct
une nouvelle fois une majorité de
français s'est donc prononcé pour la
création d'une europe réellement unie et
populaire
doté d'un gouvernement européen contrôlé
par un parlement élu démocratiquement en
dépit de ce sondage
en dépit de cette majorité la position
du gouvernement français dans les
instances européennes n'a été en rien
modifié le gouvernement français
continue d'opposer son veto formel à l'
élection du parlement européen au
suffrage universel direct continue
d'imposer au sein du conseil de la
communauté que les décisions soient
prises à l'unanimité
c'est à dire ne soit jamais prise et
continuent de réaffirmer inlassablement
son attachement à une conception aussi
lu juin qu'anachronique de
l'indépendance nationale
de ce fait
l'europe sap et dans ses fondements
ébranlé est devenu aujourd'hui le champ
clos où s'affrontent les égoïsmes
nationaux et l'europe est incapable et
les états-unis - encore bien entendu
l'europe est incapable de régler les
grands problèmes de notre temps qui se
traite sans elle la crise énergétique la
paupérisation du tiers-monde la sécurité
internationale le désordre monétaire et
la destruction de l'environnement telles
sont notamment les raisons de ma
candidature présentée par le mouvement
fédéraliste européen
nous n'avons pas l'intention de
recueillir tous les suffrages de cette
majorité de français elle qu'elle s'est
exprimée sur la participation des
travailleurs dans l'entreprise une
participation authentique sur la
régionalisation et sur le rap mais nous
voulons faire entendre la voix de cette
majorité de français est imposée aux
candidats des partis politiques
traditionnels qu'il soit au pouvoir ou
souhaitez accéder de ne plus escamoté
ces problèmes le mouvement fédéraliste
européen veut en même temps présenté je
le ferai pendant la campagne son projet
global de société un projet forgé par
trente ans de réflexion et d'action
[Musique]